need motivation with believe nation to
get ready to chase your dreams play
smart and stick to your goals with our
take on Evan Carmichael's top 10 rules
of success volume 12
all right let's kick it off with rule
number 1 chase your dream she's seen
down your dream even if everyone around
you thinks you're crazy is the only way
you're gonna win I like to say that
everybody has Michael Jordan novel
talent it's something everyone yes you
you right there you you could be the
greatest of all time at something the
problem is most of us settle for
something just over survival something
just good enough to get by instead of
going for something that you could be
the greatest of all time at the toughest
choice I ever had to make in my life was
whether I should become an entrepreneur
or go take this six-figure job traveling
around the world in investment banking
and I thought I wanted to be an
investment banker but I had this think
line not at me saying I need to at least
try this entrepreneurship path just to
test just to see nobody in my family was
an entrepreneur I didn't have an
upbringing of entrepreneurship I didn't
have heroes or role models around me who
are entrepreneurs if I wanted to model
and be like them I thought I wanted to
be a banker but when this opportunity
came up I did not want to live with
regret that's the final filter through
which I made my decision I looked at the
two decisions this is where you can't
just make your list when you're faced
with a really tough decision you have to
make your big decisions with your heart
and it's small once with the head what
do I do
the most difficult decision of my life
what do i do do I take this job or do I
try to be an entrepreneur make $300 a
month and have 30% of a company what's
that what's the best call I did not want
to live with regret I asked myself if
I'm a hundred years old and I'm sitting
on a rocking chair and I'm in a
retirement home and and I'm about to go
this is it this is what the end of my
life when I look back on this moment
right now
look back on it what will I regret more
saying no to the job or saying no to the
business I thought you know what I can
always get another job I could I mean
it'd be the same job it may not be in
Asia like this one was I'm gonna be
traveling as much but I can get another
job that's similar this business I don't
know if I'm ever gonna get the shot
again I don't know I don't know if this
will ever come around again I'm gonna
regret it if I don't know and I doubted
the mentality that I would rather know
and fail than not know I had to know
rule number two
play smart I hate spending money until
I'm making money I think this is how so
many people end up going broke you take
all the money you have pour it into your
business and because you don't know what
you're doing yet you fail end up losing
everything taking that one shot may mean
you're in debt for the rest of your life
I want you to take a smarter path so I
look at my youtube channel as an example
I've started this channel ten years ago
it's crazy just over ten years ago what
a crazy ride but when I started it I had
nothing and I didn't want to spend my
money on hiring a bunch of people an
invest into gear and equipment and
everything else and so I started by just
asking a friend of mine mark who's been
a longtime friend of the channel if he
would come and fill me he had a video
production company at the time said mark
can you come and fill me for one episode
and he did and he came in and he filmed
me and it was a lot of work and a lot of
anything afterwards but he did it
because he was a buddy of mine but he
wouldn't do every video like that and so
I had to find other ways I had to borrow
equipment from my friends and when I
couldn't borrow their camera anymore
I used the I want I want to pull for my
cell phone but it they did this didn't
exist 10 years ago I didn't I didn't
have this capability 10 years ago I used
whatever phone I had whatever camera I
had these tiny little things I don't
remember the flip cam that I would just
prop up on on a desk in front of me on a
bookcase and it would tilt and so the
video itself would be a little bit
looking like it was moving because it
wasn't it wasn't fully stable sitting
there on the shelf I sold my business I
had made some money I had another
successful business my web
had eight people on my team but I don't
want to spend money till I'm making
money I don't think that's a healthy
practice maybe I'm a little too
risk-averse maybe I care too much about
protecting my capital I don't know there
are some people who go in and they they
take out a huge loan and invest
everything they have and and sometimes
they hit sometimes you hit that's that's
the appeal that's the attraction
sometimes it's gonna hit but most of the
time it's not rule number three stick
with your goals
most people don't hit their big goals
because they don't believe that they can
because you've trained yourself that
when you set a goal and when it gets
hard you quit if you're on a diet and
that food comes in and it smells oh so
good you eat it you're training yourself
then you set goals and don't follow
through you set goals and you don't
follow through you set an alarm to wake
up at a certain time and you hit the
snooze button first thing in the morning
you set a goal and you did not follow
through and so now when you set new
goals you've trained yourself you've
conditioned yourself that I'm the kind
of person who doesn't follow through so
instead of do it anyway I'd switch it to
do it because I said I would
sticking with your goals doing it when
it's hard that's how you build
self-respect self-esteem and
self-confidence rule number four do
difficult things you don't want an easy
life you don't want to sit on the beach
and just be served drinks all day long
that might sound appealing right now if
you hate your life but it's not what you
actually want you want to do difficult
things your self confidence self-respect
self-esteem comes from doing difficult
things you want to be on a hero you want
to be on a journey you want to make an
impact all of the heroes that you look
up to right now look at where they came
from look at the journey they went on
they suffered a lot of pain to get there
you want to follow a similar road so
don't hate the pain recognize it for
what it is your chance to show yourself
in the world what you're made of
so I recently came back from doing my
tour 23 cities 90 days and I broke my
neck along the way and thank you
everybody for the warm wishes and having
you guys in my back pocket sending me
all the love every day was was super
helpful and I appreciate you and so many
people saw me doing what I was doing
with this giant net brakes on with this
huge you know cut and scar across my
forehead it's at this side yeah this ice
is still a little bit of a scar right
there they saw that and said man you're
so inspiring I see you in the hospital
still doing a livestream and I am
telling myself some BS excuse as to why
I can't get up and go to work and and
that's amazing and then that's uplifting
but the real reason why I did it why I
kept going wasn't to try to be an
inspiration to everybody watching it was
to be an inspiration to myself it was to
show myself what I could do is that I'm
in pain every day at the beginning they
had this crazy concussion but then once
that subsided I still had I still had
pain I'm still in pain that this is
months later and I'm still in pain I'm
still recovering I'm still going to
rehab just that hurts like so much it's
crazy I'm still in pain but I want to
make myself proud I want to be an
inspiration to myself because when you
do difficult things and you get through
it that's how you build self-love not by
taking it easy and only doing the things
that are within your comfort zone if
you're in your comfort zone all day long
you hate your life it means that you're
setting tiny goals for yourself that you
know you're going to accomplish and
you're basically just photocopying your
life every day is the same is the same
is the same and it's all inside your
comfort zone that's not why humans are
built to do you want to grow you're a
hero you want to go on a journey you
want to do amazing things you want to
help others also if you want to have
more confidence check out our 254 series
they're free and the link to join is in
the description below surround yourself
with greatness if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
the people who win work the hardest
because they love what they do
what I'm really helpful for me was to
create an outline in the star rule
number five hate mediocrity to make a
real change you have to hate your life
good is the enemy of great if you're
good you're good it would be nice to
have more but you're not willing to do
the crazy scary painful things that
require to get great because you're good
you need to realize if only for a few
moments that you hate your life you hate
it you're capable of more way more this
is nowhere near this is nowhere near max
you know this is nowhere near the max in
your capabilities you should hate that
you need to hate that and then you make
a powerful decision to change so if
you've ever been to a Tony Robbins
unleash the power with an event the
three and a half day event his most
powerful exercises that he does is his
Dickens exercise and what he has you do
is write down your limiting beliefs he
has he write down what are the things
that that you do that is holding you
back the belief system you have that is
holding you back the things that you
know you need to act on that you're not
doing why is it that you're not doing it
and what does it holding you back from
accomplishing and that's a great thought
exercise but unless it's emotional
you're not going to take action right
you know fixing that would be nice to be
good it'd be nice right yes but you
still like your life it's the problem
you don't hate your life you're not
desperate enough to make that happen you
think well I'll do it tomorrow do it
next week I'll do it next year no you
need to hate your life right now or that
thing will never happen
and so what Tony has you do is you take
those three limiting beliefs and then
you project forward and it takes you
down I think five years and ten years
and twenty years into the future so now
you're matching your life five years
into the future that thing that you're
afraid to do that thing that you have
when your head that limiting belief of
yours you haven't fixed it yet what's
the result what happens what do you look
like in five years and you still haven't
done the thing what happens doing five
years and then in ten years and then in
twenty years it takes you deeper into
the pain basically each time that your
life is terrible right you've never
fixed this thing you never chase that
opportunity you never go after the thing
you know you're
Belov and he puts so much pain on you
through this exercise blast I don't know
maybe 20 minutes he puts so much pain on
you but then it forces you to want to
make the change right now and then he'll
snap you back that the idea isn't let's
stay negative forever right as
entrepreneurs we don't we don't want to
do that I don't want to be negative
forever it's using negativity and
negative forces in a really acute sense
in these little pockets these little
moments to force you forward to force
you into action because when you hate
something you're gonna change it when
you've hated something in your life it's
an immediate change I need to make that
change immediately but again when you're
good you're good you don't do anything
about it and so whatever it is that you
want it alive you have to be desperate
to go and chase it down you have to I'm
the only way to do that is to hate your
current situation rule number six
surround yourself with success raising
your game starts with raising your
standards raising your standards starts
with raising your environment and
raising your environment starts with a
decision to make it so I just finished
my three day workshop here in Toronto or
I teach people how to become thought
leaders and transform them so they can
take the ideas that they have here in
their head and blow it out to the world
start building a business making money
having an impact and I was super
fortunate to have two people there at
the workshop who I've known for a decade
plus friends of mine who I've known for
a long time typically as people who fly
in from around the world but I was
really grateful to have these two people
here and it was a really interesting
conversation that came out of it from
both of them and then that led to my
wife and other people who have known
said over the last two years Evan you've
really turned it up a notch you you seem
to have access a different level and and
I want to know how I can access that too
I know I felt it too I mean it's great
hearing it from these people who know me
but but I know I felt it too
and maybe you guys have felt it too if
you watch back in my videos at a two
three five years old you've seen a shift
I'm still talking about believe a lot of
the message is exactly the same but
confidence the standards expectations
have gone up in the videos I've gotten
better I care more now how did that
happen
I'm not some magical unicorn creature
you can do it too it happened because I
chose to continue to surround myself
with excellence with the videos I make
my videos for me the top tens that
mentor means this seer I can make it for
me because I want to be around
excellence every day and here's what
happens when you around people who are
pushing the limits and doing amazing
things every day
slowly it seeps into you doesn't happen
on a daily basis but it's a cumulative
effect we wrap you around Steve Jobs an
AP Giannini and one my parents and
Howard Schultz and Kanye West fear
around them every day if they're talking
in your ear every day if you watch the
top ten cement armies every day you're
around it slowly it's gonna seep into
you the more you're around success the
more that success mindset will seep into
you it just will and what that does is
change your perspective and gives you
more confidence and gives you more
courage and that made me step up that
maybe go and do things that otherwise it
would have been scared to do that made
me go and do this crazy tour of 90 days
23 cities when I broke my neck and then
kept going on the tour all of these
things that seemed impossible to me at
the time that then I said I'm gonna do
it the thing that gave me the strength
and courage to do it is all of the
content that I've been consuming it's
the people I surround myself with who've
had success that make me want to be more
successful myself rule number seven
break free where you start from does not
have to be where you end up you didn't
choose your parents your community your
neighborhood you didn't choose that
being born but at some point you become
an adult and then it does become a
choice to stay exactly where you are or
break free all of your heroes all the
people you look up to all the people you
respect they want to be like they
started with less than what you already
have right now they started from a worse
upbringing from fewer opportunities at
what you currently have
to you right now so you have to decide
do you want to win big like they did you
want to escape you want to break free do
you want to come back and be an
inspiration and lift the world around
you up or do you want to blame complain
about where you started and stay there
forever rule number eight don't fear
rejection rejection leads to success all
you have to do is look at the people
that you look up to look at the people
that are profiled on my youtube channels
and what you'll find is rejection after
rejection after rejection so rejection
leads to success you know this
intellectually you already know this but
when you get into the situation where
you have to face rejection then your
emotions take over your fears take over
and you don't do the thing that you
might get rejected for even though you
know logically because in that moment
your emotions your fear are greater than
your logic I had a life-changing fear of
rejection situation happens to me in
Paris when I was 18 years old and I was
there when I was on the street outside
the notre-dame Cathedral and I have a
map in front of me and this cute girl
comes up to me she asks for directions
and I want to ask her out and it was too
afraid I was too embarrassed I was too
ashamed I was too worried that I might
get rejected in my head the only thing I
could think of was I want to ask her out
and she might reject me she might say no
and so what did I do nothing now if I
had logically stood to the side pressed
I'm out you know pause the situation say
Evan logically what makes sense
logically you know she might say no and
you're okay you move on with rest your
day logically she might say yes why is
why is she coming up to you asking for
directions why is she asking for
directions when she already speaks
perfect French and she seems like a
local right logically that's what makes
the most sense logically I should have
someone the courage to go off and do it
but in the moment your emotions take
over your fear takes over that idea that
you might get rejected takes over and so
what did I do nothing I let her walk
away
and ever since that day I reminded
myself that I would rather no one failed
and not know and I use that painful
moment to whenever I am thinking about
doing something I'm afraid of rejection
for afraid of it not working out that I
have to do it that that moment is what
led me to become an entrepreneur because
a year later when I had the chance to
have my dream job and make 100k a year
travel around the world or be an
entrepreneur own 30 percent of a
business and make $300 a month I had
that picture in my head where I was
thinking I can't let this happen again I
don't want to live with regret I would
rather know and fail than not know rule
number nine have a cause having a cause
will make you feel like a superhero it
allow you to do things you never thought
you'd do and give you the courage you'd
never thought you'd have all of your
heroes had a cause and if you want to
stop selling sugar water and change the
world it's time to find yours
I love the Steve Jobs story I'm a huge
fan of Steve I have his poster on my
wall as one of five people that look up
to on a daily basis but one of the
things that I really find most valuable
about having a cause is it can allow you
to have the courage to be the
evangelical person even if it's not
naturally who you are I look at Steve
Jobs and I see someone who is naturally
talented who is a great salesperson who
has the gift of gab who loves being in
the spotlight who is that person who
likes being up front and center and so
it's easy to go off and be that person
now you combine that with a cause and
you get a company like Apple but having
a cause can make you evangelical even if
you are introvert and shy and don't like
the spotlight I know because I'm talking
about myself I am an introvert I don't
like talking to people I don't talk to
the person next to me on the airplane
being in front of the camera makes me
nervous
being in front of a giant audience makes
me shied much rather be at the back of a
room than be the center of attention one
of the things they used to fight the
most with my age in the boat was he
would say that Evan you don't want to be
famous that's a problem like yeah I
don't want to be famous it's not about
me it's about the cause and recently it
started to sink in that by me becoming
more famous I could spread the message
more but it's one of the biggest things
that we kept fighting
because I don't crave the limelight
where a lot of people they absolutely
have to have it but when you have a car
that forces you to the front I make
videos because I want to help
entrepreneurs I make videos because I
struggled so much your purpose comes in
your pain I struggled someone can start
in my business I want to make the path a
little bit easier for the next
generation of people coming through I'm
making videos and content and speeches
for the 19 year old version of myself
that needed to hear this stuff and so I
feel it's my responsibility it's my
obligation I have to do it and it forces
me out into stages that normally I would
say you're crazy I'm on this tour right
now
right I gave up a quarter of my year 90
days they hit 23 cities and do the thing
that I'm most afraid to do which is get
up and potentially disappoint people
every four days by doing another event
and I kept going even though I broke my
neck I broke my neck three weeks ago in
Denver and and we kept going I only
canceled one event completely and it
just got up and kept going and so having
that cause feeling like the work that
you do is important and meaningful is
the whole thing and rule and pretend the
last one before a very special bonus
clip be practical your vision alone is
not enough doing what you love is the
number one rule for success from
everybody that I've covered but doing
what you love following your vision is
not enough you need to balance it with
what actually works this is why so many
people fall down and fail if you just
have a vision but don't pay attention to
the trends your vision will never happen
it will die within you is Simon's vision
is to help people be inspired to go to
work I love it that's awesome I'm on the
same page that is a joint vision amazing
but how you go about doing it matters
he's not doing it through smoke signals
in my space right that era is gone but
he's also not doing it through virtual
reality Anna in hologram Simon's coming
into your living room right that era has
not arrived yet how you approach the
work matters so how does Simon do it he
does it mostly through his books right
start with why he does it through his
speaking the TED talk that launched his
whole career right how did Simon get his
mission to take
how did Simon get people even aware
about his vision well he started by
doing it just helping his friends right
he was he was just being a good friend
helping the mau and he said you should
go and speak and then he created that
ted talk and he blew up he blew up
through his TEDx talk that became a TED
talk and YouTube and then through his
books right if he was not paying
attention to the trends if he did not go
do his TED talk if he did not get on
YouTube if he did not write the book if
it was not marketing in the era that we
are in right now if he was not paying
attention to the trends that oh people
watch youtube videos oh people go to TED
talks oh people read books if he wasn't
paying attention to those trends nobody
would know simon Sinek that's the
problem you start with the vision 100%
juice paying attention to the trends is
not enough you start with the vision but
you have to know the trends too it's
always both and now I have a special
bonus clip from Evan on how to take
accountability that I think you'll enjoy
but before that here's our three point
landing questions to make sure that
we're not just watching we're taking
massive action in our life here we go
question number one what's one thing
that you're afraid of that you can do
this week to make yourself proud number
two what are three goals you can set out
for yourself that you can crush this
week and three what can you do today to
surround yourself with more success it's
not fair you're right it is not fair the
situation that you're in the people
around you the lack of resources that
you have it is not fair I agree with you
so now what because you will have a very
important choice to make the past does
not have to equal the future where you
started from does not have to be where
you end up all of your heroes overcame
bigger obstacles and what's in front of
you right now so now what are you going
to take accountability and create a new
life or keep complaining about how your
current life is not fair
if you want to see Evans top 50 rules
for success check out the video next to
me continue to believe and we'll see you
there
if you have to get motivated every
single day then you are in the wrong
business the people who win work the
hardest because they love what they do I
hate spending money till on making money